the first video I made on Medusa is by
far the most popular on my channel and
it's a video that solicited a lot of
emotion positive and negative but it's a
story with so many variations each one
changing the way we see the individuals
that were involved the version I talk is
perhaps the most dramatized and as a
result two people have formed opinions
and made assumptions without really
understanding what the story even
symbolizes today we'll be going over the
variant accounts of how a Medusa became
a Gorgon and how each story changes our
view of the Gods involved but before I
begin I'd like to thank everyone who
supported the channel it means a lot to
me I know it's a tad bit late but to
celebrate reaching 50,000 subscribers
I've been in contact of the good people
at statue King Khan who've agreed to
sponsor this giveaway and send one of my
subscribers this awesome statue of
Medusa if you guys and girls would like
to enter the giveaway and stick around
to the end of the video where I'll be
telling you how to do so we story that I
previously told of Medusa was one when
she was caught in between the conflict
of Poseidon and Athena Poseidon used
Medusa knowing that taken advantage of
one of the thinnest priestesses would
anger her and as a result
Medusa was also punished by Athena who
couldn't physically direct her anger
towards Poseidon because of his position
in the Greek pantheon it's almost like
expecting a child to punish an adult
with Poseidon's status and immense power
he was somewhat untouchable that a vast
majority of gods or goddesses I've seen
a lot of people especially in the
comments of the previous video almost
disgusted by the actions of Poseidon and
Athena saying that isn't how gods should
behave and to me that seemed like a
pretty ridiculous thing to say gods and
goddesses from mythology all around the
world are rarely ever painted as these
angelic figures who never do anything
wrong there are of course examples of
gods who uphold justice in the law but
if every God was perfect and never made
mistakes
they'd have no personality no defining
characteristics stories about mythology
would not only be extremely boring but
I'm relatable whether you believe humans
were made in the mode of gods or stories
of gods are constructed by humans then
our behavior would only mirror there's
one of the main reasons I believe Greek
mythology is so popular is because the
gods are far from
fect we have these extremely powerful
beings who face dilemmas of morality
similar to the ones we do as humans and
that's something we can relate to
regardless of the shape or form these
gods take you can look at Medusa's story
in a cynical manner which I've seen a
lot of people do you can blame the
ancient Greeks for being misogynistic
and promoting rape culture which is
sadly a comment that I've read many
times or you can take a look at the
bigger picture we don't live in a
perfect world bad things happen to good
people all the time but just like a
Medusa if you don't allow these in
justices to shape the type of person you
become the outcome will always be
positive
even after Medusa was killed her head
was used to ward off evil and she became
a symbol of protection the symbol of
Medusa's head was even painted on
women's shelters in Greece to show them
that these were places where they could
be safe
another interesting variation of this
story that entirely changes the way you
perceive Athena involves Medusa's curse
when Athena had seen what had happened
to Medusa she turned her into a Gorgon
this is quite often seen as the curse
but in this variation it was more of a
gift
Medusa became a Gorgon so no one could
ever take advantage of her in the same
way ever again in this variation of the
story
Athena provided Medusa loved the means
to protect herself and she goes from
being regarded as a villain
being called every name under the Sun to
a wise and caring goddess it's these
small variations of stories in Greek
mythology that remind us we shouldn't be
so quick to judge
gods and goddesses can quickly go from
villain to hero and vice versa
even the role Poseidon plays in this
story can change drastically depending
on the interpretation in some stories
Poseidon didn't take advantage of Medusa
at all when Athena saw the two together
she immediately assumed the worst
and turned Medusa into a monster so
nothing like that could ever happen
again
there are even stories where Medusa came
willingly to Poseidon and she was
punished by Athena for her betrayal
accordingly if you find yourself
disliking the gods in Greek mythology or
even other mythologies because you don't
consider their behavior to be godlike
and that's most likely because what
you're seeing is a reflection of our own
attitudes and behavior as humans to
somewhat summarize what's been said in
this video if you want to enjoy
mythology
especially Greek mythology then you need
to remove the gods from this moral
pedestal and accept that controversy be
it good or bad will always be a part of
storytelling because it's a part of
everyday life every movie in the film
has a problem that needs to be fixed
something bad that happens that the
entire movie is shaped around if we
remove this problem and pretend that
every person is good and just than like
mythology movies would soon cease to
exist I hope everyone enjoyed today's
video for those of you guys who stuck
around waiting to hear about the
giveaway we're going to go over that
right now
so the fantastic people over at statue
King Khan have agreed to sponsor this
video and send one of my subscribers
this statue of Medusa they have
previously sent me a statue of Odin
which I absolutely love and I'll leave a
link in the description for you guys to
check out their website they sell a host
of mythology rated statues as well as
other things and shipping to anywhere in
the United States is free now the
giveaway sadly will only be available to
residents of the United States for those
of you who don't live in America are we
trying to do a separate giveaway at
another time but please don't enter if
you don't live in the u.s. because the
statue won't be sent to you to enter the
giveaway all you guys have to do is
leave a comment as you normally would
but in the comment of hashtag Medusa and
a week from now I'll be choosing the
winner at random make sure if you enter
the giveaway you have your youtube
messages enabled so I can contact you
and ask for a ship and address I'll also
be announcing the winner on Twitter so
if you guys would like to know who won
you can follow me over there there'll be
a link in the description below if you
do like the look of any of these statues
you've seen today then feel free to
check out statue king calm the statues
make really good gifts and they look
amazing on a desktop or mantelpiece I
wish all of you guys the best of luck
with the giveaway and as always I've
been your host mythology and fiction
explained
you